when it comes to like athletic spaces I
don't think that trans women should be
allowed into athletic spaces because I
don't think it's a fair
um I think as female athletes we work so
incredibly hard for the little
opportunity there is in women's sports
would this be a barrier like this
there's no barrier there's less
opportunity in some Industries there's
less it's not no no no it's based on the
marketing okay hold on hold on guys okay
so again we work very hard for the
little opportunity there is in the space
because we're not as entertaining as the
men sorry we're just not and so it's
like you're going to take the little
opportunity that we're given and the
problem is like
we can't compete we can't like I'm six
foot if I go up against a six foot guy
and I play basketball with him he's
gonna body me and what happens
even even if I have years more of
training and so it's like you're taking
away the little opportunity that we're
given and we all work so hard for